Saugus high school has more than 2,000
students and it conducts regular
lockdown drills but many students say
they never thought they would have to
put their training to use that all
changed when they heard yesterday's
gunfire Jonathan Vigliotti spoke to two
sisters who saw the horror unfold at
first I thought it was fake mica Turner
had just arrived at the school quad
Thursday morning when gunshots rang out
I just saw him fire one two three I just
saw it like I'm just a body fall and I
my first instinct was to get out of
there and to find my sister amidst the
chaos her sister Samara was hiding in a
classroom I was just like freaking out
cuz I heard the gunshots loud and clear
cuz it left a little ring in my ear
Jeff Turner had just returned home when
he heard the news from his wife she hops
in the truck and says go back to the
park there's a shooting at the high
school it took about 45 minutes for the
family to reunite but it felt like a
lifetime and I just started crying
hysterically because I saw we opened the
car door she got in and then she just
jumped on me in the back seat and then I
held her for like a good minute or two
and we were both is crying and just
relieved that we were finally together
what sticks in your mind as we talk
about now his face and just seeing that
one person fall it's gonna be hard to
forget when I'm gonna have to live with
that sight in my head I know for a fact
this will be with her the rest of her
life and that it makes me so angry yeah
you don't see this stuff I was thinking
about that too because once you see it
you're right Tony you'll never be able
to unsee it I just think of all the
trauma we hear about the shooting and we
hear about the death toll but it's so
much bigger the legacy of trauma is so
powerful it's changing the way feels not
only for students for teachers for
everybody involved in the educational
environment as so important to
understand these incidents don't end
when the
gunman is caught or dies then go on for
everything and it's an endless legend
remains how many more do we have to see
yes before we do something about it